GREG CASTLE: So when
we were thinking
about the ideas
for this talk, we
were kind of
looking at customers
who were trying to isolate
things within their cluster.
And so a typical
scenario is you have
some sort of trusted
workload and some sort
of untrusted workload.
The examples we use in the
talk are a payment system
is the trusted
side, and a company
that is doing web
hosting has a container
that's provided by a customer.
And that's basically
untrusted code
from a security perspective,
and so people want
to separate these things out.
So you could use a cluster
boundary, but a lot of people
are actually looking at
kind of putting the trusted
thing on trusted nodes
and the untrusted thing
on untrusted nodes, so
using a VM and a node,
effectively, to separate
those two kinds of workloads.
And that is a pretty comfortable
place for security people.
They are used to
separating things with VMs,
but in Kubernetes, it's
actually a little bit different.
There's actually quite a lot
of connections between nodes
and a lot of
privilege that's held
by nodes that makes
that isolation
just probably not as good as
a lot of people think it is.
And so we really wanted to
highlight that in this talk
and give a practical
demonstration
of how to break that
isolation and talk
about some alternatives.
Tim, do you want to talk
about node versus pod,
and what the
alternatives are there?
TIM ALLCLAIR: Yeah, sure.
So the node is
really complicated.
There's a lot of stuff
going on, and the attacker--
an attacker who has
compromised the node
has access to the union of
all of those different things
that the node is using.
They have a pretty
large toolkit,
even if you're running
the least privileged.
And so we kind of compare
what the attacker has access
to in the node with
what they have access
to in the pod, which you
can scope down much more,
and this slide summarizes
the differences there.
And then we wrap up by looking
at what you can actually
do to defend, in addition to--
or instead of node isolation.
Before the attacker can
get to actually leveraging
all of those privileges
at the node level,
they first have to go
through your application,
getting remote code execution.
They then need to break
out of the container,
and only then can they get
access to the whole node.
So first, we recommend
hardening the application.
Then we look at different ways
of hardening the container,
and we talk about sandboxes,
like GKE sandboxes with gVisor
as a way of hardening that
hard boundary a lot more.
And then we see
that, at that point,
node isolation
isn't as critical.
So we finish off by
talking about how
nodes are really
complicated and shouldn't
be your only measure of
defense, and instead, we
recommend using container
isolation and pod sandboxing
as a much more secure
form of isolation.
GREG CASTLE: So I hope
you enjoy the talk.
And we'll be hanging
out at the Google booth,
so please come by
and talk to us if you
want to talk about security and
GKE and isolation or anything
else.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]